c'est un moment historique de
réconciliation
c'est un moment que tout le monde attend
mais on vit dans ce contexte de pandémie
al'approche de la visite du pape
françois à québec judith gagnon lance un
appel à la prudence pour les aînés qui
envisagent de participer à l'événement
faut vraiment faire attention il ya des
petits gestes sont importants en vo à
être plusieurs pour aller voir le pacte
mettez votre masque essayer d'être moins
passé avec d'autres personnes que les
organisateurs prenaient soin des gens
spéculent intensiviste mathieu simon
partage l'avis de judith gagnon selon
lui les personnes vulnérables devront se
protéger pour éviter que l'événement
auquel devraient assister des dizaines
de milliers de personnes ne devienne une
source d'éclosion sont peut-être âgés
ils sont peut-être vulnérables ce serait
très dommage qu'ils obtiennent la
reconnaissance qu'il soit et puis qui
reviennent de là avec une reconnaissance
peut s'auto qu'un virus qui risque de
leur occasionné beaucoup de troupes une
étude qui n'est pas partagé par tout le
monde surtout aux membres gm reculé mais
j'irai pas dans la foule c'est sûr et
certain vous allez venir voir leurs
attentes comme un jeu contente que le
pape vienne
et puis il faut que les gens se
comportent de façon prudente donc ça
m'inquiète pas
problème
pour nous autres on est produit comme
partout dans la province lakovic 19 et
en progression dans la capitale
nationale et la pression est forte pour
les services hospitaliers c'est ce
qu'elle voit les rassemblements de 300
vies a senti sa cellule n 9 se servent
des personnes âgées c'est sûr que c'est
inquiétant puis c'est ce que c'est sûr
on n'a pas à l'heure actuelle nos
urgences débordent déjà bien au noir je
fais encore si ce que vous dites c'est
que malgré tout selon les dernières
données disponibles parmi les 274
personnes hospitalisées en lien avec la
coved 19 dans la grande région de québec
seul huit se trouve aux soins intensifs
ici flavie sauvageau radio canada québec